approximately 50,000 to 70,000 people,
who live in this community of self-built
multi-story houses
where up to three generations live in one structure.
While these apartments that they built for themselves
appear to lack any planning or formal grid,
each family specializing in a certain form of recycling
means that the ground floor of each apartment
is reserved for garbage-related activities
and the upper floor is dedicated to living space.
I find it incredible to see
how these piles and piles of garbage
are invisible to the people who live there,
like this very distinguished man who is posing
while all this garbage is sort of streaming out behind him,
or like these two young men who are sitting
and chatting amongst these tons of garbage.
While to most of us, living amongst
these piles and piles of garbage
may seem totally uninhabitable,
to those in the Zabbaleen, this is just
a different type of normal.
In all these places I've talked about today,
what I do find fascinating is that there's really
no such thing as normal,
and it proves that people are able to adapt
to any kind of situation.
Throughout the day, it's quite common
to come across a small party taking place
in the streets, just like this engagement party.
In this tradition, the bride-to-be
displays all of their belongings,
which they soon bring to their new husband.
A gathering like this one
offers such a juxtaposition
where all the new stuff is displayed
and all the garbage is used
as props to display all their new home accessories.
Like Makoko and the Torre David,
throughout the Zabbaleen you'll find all
the same facilities as in any typical neighborhood.
There are the retail shops, the cafes
and the restaurants, and the community
is this community of Coptic Christians,
so you'll also find a church,
along with the scores of religious iconographies
throughout the area,
and also all the everyday services
like the electronic repair shops,
the barbers, everything.
Visiting the homes of the Zabbaleen
is also full of surprises.
While from the outside,
these homes look like any other informal structure
in the city, when you step inside,
you are met with all manner of design decisions
and interior decoration.
Despite having limited access to space and money,
the homes in the area are designed
with care and detail.
Every apartment is unique,
and this individuality tells a story
about each family's circumstances and values.
Many of these people take their homes
and interior spaces very seriously,
putting a lot of work and care
into the details.
The shared spaces are also treated in the same manner,
where walls are decorated in faux marble patterns.
But despite this elaborate decor,
sometimes these apartments are used
in very unexpected ways,
like this home which caught my attention
while all the mud and the grass was literally
seeping out under the front door.
When I was let in, it appeared that this fifth-floor apartment
was being transformed into a complete animal farm,
where six or seven cows stood grazing
in what otherwise would be the living room.
But then in the apartment across the hall
from this cow shed lives a newly married couple
in what locals describe
as one of the nicest apartments in the area.
The attention to this detail astonished me,
and as the owner of the home so proudly
led me around this apartment,
from floor to ceiling, every part was decorated.
But if it weren't for the strangely familiar
stomach-churning odor that constantly
passes through the apartment,
it would be easy to forget
that you are standing next to a cow shed
and on top of a landfill.
What moved me the most was that despite
these seemingly inhospitable conditions,
I was welcomed with open arms
into a home that was made with love, care,
and unreserved passion.
Let's move across the map to China,
to an area called Shanxi, Henan and Gansu.
In a region famous for the soft, porous Loess Plateau soil,
there lived until recently an estimated
40 million people in these houses underground.
These dwellings are called the yaodongs.
Through this architecture by subtraction,
these yaodongs are built literally inside of the soil.
In these villages, you see an entirely altered landscape,
and hidden behind these mounds of dirt
are these square, rectangular houses
which sit seven meters below the ground.
When I asked people why they were digging
their houses from the ground,
they simply replied that they are poor wheat
and apple farmers who didn't have the money
to buy materials, and this digging out
was their most logical form of living.
From Makoko to Zabbaleen, these communities
have approached the tasks of planning,
design and management of their communities
and neighborhoods in ways that respond
specifically to their environment and circumstances.
Created by these very people who live,
work and play in these particular spaces,
these neighborhoods are intuitively designed
to make the most of their circumstances.
In most of these places, the government
is completely absent, leaving inhabitants
with no choice but to reappropriate found materials,
and while these communities are highly disadvantaged,
they do present examples
of brilliant forms of ingenuity,
and prove that indeed we have the ability
to adapt to all manner of circumstances.
What makes places like the Torre David
particularly remarkable
is this sort of skeleton framework
where people can have a foundation
where they can tap into.
Now imagine what these already ingenious communities
could create themselves,
and how highly particular their solutions would be,
if they were given the basic infrastructures
that they could tap into.
Today, you see these large residential development projects
which offer cookie-cutter housing solutions
to massive amounts of people.
From China to Brazil, these projects attempt
to provide as many houses as possible,
but they're completely generic
and simply do not work as an answer
to the individual needs of the people.
I would like to end with a quote
from a friend of mine and a source of inspiration,
Zita Cobb, the founder of the wonderful
Shorefast Foundation,
based out of Fogo Island, Newfoundland.
She says that "there's this plague of sameness
which is killing the human joy,"
and I couldn't agree with her more.
Thank you.
(Applause)